ha that was stronger than I thought it
would be what I would expect from
Japanese alcohol is that it will
annihilate you
oh they like their karaoke and you need
a lot of courage for that so I reckon
that it's probably gonna knock my socks
off gonna be hardcore made from sweet
potatoes like a hash brown on the bottle
25% alcohol this is awesome with Gauri
and slip us a little bit um
paint thinner II kind of mushroom that's
something that you regret instantly this
looks classy chit
that's lovely I didn't risk that's like
the perfect summer drink it's like a
Gatorade like an alcoholic Gatorade well
you like that hit the spot
my only problem with it is that it's
only ones to hit a drink which is not
enough no do you have a carton I'll take
one now so we've got the Demon Slayer
sake yeah I think it's a game of Thrones
paraphernalia demons found this sake so
delicious they would gather drink it and
then just pass out which sounds awesome
that's just a life--all that's lovely
hmm
I feel like I just drank a potato I have
a scooter of that yeah I could do that
all day
this reminds me of like watered-down
goon rock up to a party with that yeah
darn it sweet japanese-style desert
liquor I'm into that I'm down with that
let's pour tea it is pour tea YUM mmm
mmm mmm
delightful yeah it tastes like medicine
- the cherry and - the antibiotics it's
pretty sweet
same mmm when you've had you know a nice
steak or a big meal that's the last
thing you have
this is plum wine this is a huge profit
our minute hmm so there's a testicle in
there ah that it's super sweet a little
bit like children's cough medicine my
cordial x-rays yes i cordial mother's
Shandy is it oh really that has sucked
up a lot of liquor I would not eat this
again or drink that again that was not
good I thought the Japanese they know
what they're doing like they don't mess
around if they're gonna make something
sweet sweet as hell it's gonna be
alcoholic it's gonna slay demons yeah
heaps drunk in Japan you're doing
something Raj Japan keep it calm all I
want to know is where are we gonna do
karaoke we've really plumbed the depths
of Japanese burgers oh that joke really
socking hey whose side are you on